[Music]
how's it going guys and welcome back to
demo rpg with c plus plus and we are
continuing to learn and go and we're on
actually a rather difficult section and
this is a section that actually most
games get wrong and most popular games
that you know when you play get this
wrong so
like pay close attention because this
little lesson here in c plus plus is
going to put you far ahead of your peers
especially if you're new to it and still
learning stuff so i hope you uh
appreciate the value of this series and
if you do hit the like button and don't
forget to also subscribe and if you want
to go to the extra mile you can hit the
join button down there on youtube or
join on the patreon to help support me
and these productions and this channel
so first i want to address what i said
all right most games get this wrong what
am i talking about you guys ever watched
the spiffing brits channel
you know how he pretty much knows how to
do items in every game
it's because the programmers don't know
how to manage memory correctly and when
you don't manage memory correctly you
leave little bugs like oh you can dupe
items if you do things in a certain
order that sort of thing happens
but don't worry because we can just say
i've got stuff for sale and she's got
all of our money just hanging around
here so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to sell her this cork bulb root
press e go into her inventory and sell
her back her own ingredients i think
fire salts are fantastic for this so
there we go we're bam you'll notice in
the bottom right we are just gaining
money and speech as we convince her to
buy her own goods off of her yes so
skyrim is just riddled with these types
of bugs it's not the only game it's not
the only one but it's a great example
and uh basically they the programmers
don't really know how to code they're
just kind of like letting things copy
and letting pointers have multiple
references to the same object and just
not controlling who owns the memory
we're not going to do that here we're
going to make it actually work properly
and we're going to make it unhackable
unless of course you go in with a
bytecode editor and decompile and change
the memory but through its actual the
way it's made to play it's going to be
impossible to break things that's what
you should aim for and that's what we're
going to aim for with all of our systems
here so a little more legit than
multi-million dollar games i know i know
right and you can get it all for free
here on youtube so please support me
okay this episode this uh yeah this is
probably gonna be multiple episodes
there's no way i'm gonna get all this
done in one let me show myself down here
okay
so you'll notice from last episode we
sorted out some equipment we got that
all mostly working and we can kind of do
some cool things with it like you know
equip upper warrior with some pieces
and he actually gets the stats from it
which is kind of cool but uh
you know we were mentioning the
inventory's not really sorted out yet so
we're gonna kind of work on that i might
not get to the inventory till next
episode because right now we're just
gonna work on expanding this beyond
equipment basically we're going to do a
similar system that we did with the
player character and uh you know if
you've been following this on github you
might notice there's been some commits
and uh stuff i'm kind of backtracking on
so this is like my third attempt at this
episode i think because this is hard
this isn't exactly easy and uh there's a
reason
why people get stuck on their
their stuff but i think i've got it
pretty well figured out now and uh
yeah i just really hope that people
actually appreciate them putting this
much time into it that's all i'm saying
because i don't wanna i don't wanna get
into that but you know what i mean and
uh yeah please
please do
uh
yeah so
yeah our character we have the whole
player character delegate we're gonna do
a similar things with items you can't
instantiate the delegate this is just
used to
have some base stuff uh for all
characters and we're probably going to
use this
later for monsters too
so it's it's expandable and you know
we'll come to that when we come to that
but for equipment we also want to do
that
this same thing like we're going to have
class
item delegate
all right and that's going to have the
based up of all that items all items are
going to have a name that's one thing
they're definitely going to have and so
equipment
uh we don't want to ever instantiate
equipment either so equipment's going to
change into a delegate
and it's going to inherit from item
delegate
because they're all items
but uh we just want equipment to
basically be you know the stuff that all
armor and weapons use and we don't ever
want to instantiate
weapon and armor uh itself
or
well we want to do it kind of like we
did with the player character class if
we go all the way down the bottom of the
player character class let's find it
it's kind of kind of grown with all the
functions we have a player character
that doesn't inherit from everything and
that from anything and that's what we
use in our actual game the rest of the
stuff is all just
boilerplate stuff
for it so we're going to do
very simple similar thing here all right
we want to make this public
and we also want to have something
uh privately i'd say no not privately
actually we'll just make it const uh
let's see
now we're gonna make it an unsigned int
but we want a unique id we're gonna have
each item have a unique id uh so unique
id
uh but uh we need to type for it let's
just use unsigned ins we'll use
uns32t
make it uh potentially pretty pretty
large and unique id
and
since it's const you're not going to be
able to change it you'll be able to
access it since it's public but never be
able to change it
now we might um it's this going to get a
little interest interesting when we're
stacking items so maybe we need to think
about that so maybe the unique id
belongs more in equipment
because equipment's not going to be
stackable in general
but things like potions might be
so we'll have like uh
yeah we're not gonna do consumables just
yet but the point is consumables aren't
exactly unique if you got like say minor
healing potions you should be able to
stack those up you don't want them to
each have their unique id so
we will keep that in mind and address
that when it comes up but for now every
single item at least has a name every
single equipment at least has a unique
id we don't need name here anymore
because we have that inherited here but
we still do need the rest of the stuff
now we have a pure virtual git type here
we're actually going to put that up here
into the item delegate now really we're
not going to use this get type we just
need something in here that is pure
virtual to make sure that
well we're going to use some
some type checking later with our
inventory
so we're just going to use this function
right now it's like a placeholder
to do
that all right so we move down to our
equipment now equipment's got a unique
id and it's got stats on it uh
so we kind of sorted out that last
episode but we've got this protected
equipment instructor which is now
equipment delegate
and uh we're gonna
make instantiate this name like so when
we a little constructor here
and we know these don't need to be
public necessarily these can be
protected uh which makes it just a
little more clear that you're not
supposed to use it in case the virtual
wasn't but it doesn't actually matter if
you make this uh public or protected but
it has to be one of them
uh standard string
name and it's gonna go name
and of course that's going to be
just name okay so something interesting
is happening here
we have this const unique id
and what's this complaining about this
is complaining it's got a little green
underline i don't know if you can see
it's kind of small but basically it's
saying that we need to set
this const to something
and
i'm not sure if we can actually do that
in a header let's see unique id
equals so if it's unique what's it gonna
be okay so this is this is a little
tricky we're gonna need something you
know a lot of people do unique ids with
some sort of hashed value and we could
do that but that's overkill so we're
just gonna increment some static
variable it and static will mean that
there can only be one of this variable
and
they'll just increment up so let's make
a static
unsigned um
id we'll just call it id iterator called
whatever you want really but we're going
to start this out at 0.
it doesn't like this why doesn't it like
this
and remember within class initializer
must be must be
const
or says a static a member with an
n-class initializer must be cause okay
so it doesn't like initializing it even
if it's static so we need this outside
the class uh we could put it like here
in the header
but that means that anyone that includes
this equipment class has access to this
and they could change it and we don't
want that to happen so because that's a
little dangerous so we're going to
change how this works a little bit let's
do
first of all let's rename this equipment
into just item
all right
because it's going to be items in
general not just equipment it's going to
be it's going to be a lot of stuff in
this file and let's make
the cpp of this all right so we're just
going to go add i click here add
new item
cpp file and just put in item and then
we got to include
item.h all right and we're gonna put
this static variable over in here
and maybe we'll make a little more
specific we'll make it uh equipment
by
unique id id iterator you know something
like that something that's clear what it
is all right now
since it's in a cvv file we can actually
initialize it
to zero
zero for unsigned
so the first when this first gets built
when this first runs this is going to
start out as zero
and now we're going to do something
interesting okay this function
right here for this equipment delegate
now we're not it's not going to know
about
this equipment id iterator so basically
we need to build this function in the
cpp file that's all right and you might
know how to do this already
it's uh you know it's just a constructor
equipment delegate
scoped to equipment delegate constructor
let's go back here copy this stuff this
the name and stats there we go
let's make a little new line here and it
wants something here
in its body and that's going to be that
unique id
this right here
so we'll go unique id equals whatever
this value is
but we're going to put a pre-increment
and there we go so it'll initialize
to this whatever this is but plus one so
there's going to be no id 0. it's going
to start out id1 because this is going
to pre-go up
and what is this complaining about now
no initializer for const member okay
well we've got it now all right so it
can't complain
maybe it still will
but that should go away expression must
be mod okay we need to do it in this
structure because this is like it's
already constructed
uh all the variables at this point
so we need to actually instruct them by
doing it like so do it up here and we
can use this pre-increment right here i
believe that's going to work
yeah and there we go
no more little green squigglies it is
happy so there we go it's going to it's
going to give everyone a unique id and
this is going to plus up every time too
so
and nobody has access to this it's in a
c plus plus file
no one in the program has access to it
uh they could get access to it if they
wanted to through a little trick but
you're not supposed to if you do you're
gonna break the software
don't change this only the
equipment delegate
we'll put comment
uh
constructor
could touch this
just in case because people could
technically they really wanted to
they could go with the main and they
could go
ahead i'll i'll sh i'll give you one
better
x turn they could get they could go like
this
and then they could have access to it
but don't do that that's that's
dangerous try to avoid extern as much as
you can
so
just so you're aware and now we have a
comment there that says it once again
just in case anybody gets it in their
head that it's a good idea but
so there you go so this basically will
isolate it to this file
and that's what we want here so now
equipment has a unique id which is what
we want not necessarily all items
but all equipment and we might do this
for other things too but you know like
quest items or something but that's kind
of for other people to decide for now uh
we're assuming there's going to be this
but
all right so let's go ahead and fix our
armor and equipment for now and work on
just a few other things so now armor
armor is going to uh here from equipment
delegate with the delegate it's going to
use this constructor which is going to
give a unique id it's also going to give
it a name from the item and all that
good stuff
there we go so it gives us a name there
all right
this one looks good
this one we need to do the same thing
and it's already pretty much good to go
now you notice in this equipment
delegate it looks like it could be
instantiated but it can't because it's
inheriting from itemdelegate an item
delegate has a pure virtual function we
are not overwriting it here which means
this is uh you can't construct this
unless you're overriding it which we you
know with armor and weapon
you can actually construct them because
we are overwriting that function so
there we go we've got four classes in
there
and
we're pretty much good to go but what we
really want is we want
an item slot all right
just like a
we don't really want to make weapons in
armor all over the place like we don't
want to have to have an inventory that
that has like
modular
well we want it to be modular but we
want it to be automatically modular that
makes sense so
rather than having
like
every little field in our inventory like
an enum that can be a bunch of things or
something what we can do is just make it
just like an item and this is going to
be
basically using the power of
what we were doing with the player
character
composition
all right so we're going to compose
together a character i guess we got to
fix equipment here too
these uh equipments are now equipped
delegate this is over in the player
character class so we'll just get that
fixed up
i think that's the only place and we're
probably gonna have to fix a few other
things here too
but for the most part it's going to be
about the same
all right let's go back to the item
let's go ahead and make
a class
it's called plain old item all right so
we'll have
and this is not going to inherit from
anything this will be the one we
actually use
and
what we're going to do here is we're
going to let's just make it all public
for now to keep it simple we're going to
have
item delegate pointer just called
uh item and this is what the item
actually is
and then and i can we need a constructor
and in this constructor
we need to take a pointer
to an item basically
so let's go item item
and it's gonna this is what's gonna
instantiate and we'll say item
uh i guess this uh
we'll just call it something else you
know this will be like the data i guess
we'll call it data underscore data that
uh that's gonna make it a little more
clear i guess
we'll just do that for now
key
and i think that works i'm saying it's a
little wrong okay this needs to be an
item delegate point right
and i itself is an item so that's that's
not going to work so we need to
instantiate this here at runtime
function definition for item not found
okay i'm not sure what it's talking
about there
but this should work
okay i'm not sure exactly why that's
messed up but if we go back to our
player character we know we renamed
equipment to items so we got to fix that
in some headers here
and that's part of the reason things are
a little wonky
so just keep that in mind um all right
so let's let's just hit compile and see
if we get any errors and we do and it
looks like it's uh we need to fix a few
more things here equipment delegate this
is in the player character just
everything that said equipment now needs
to see say equipment delegate so we can
cast as needed
uh to whatever type of equipment it is
all right let's uh at this point let's
just hit build just to sort out the
current errors we have and it looks like
it's just equipment stuff
see if there's any more
let's keep hitting build here and
it succeeds all right so we go back to
item it's still underlined but i think
it's inaccurate
sometimes visual studio just takes some
time to catch up
and uh
that's something i'm used to at this
point all right so right now everything
works if we go back to our main now
works with our new system
except any equipment we instantiate now
is going to have that unique uh
name or unique id we can have the same
name but it's going to have different
ids and that's really important uh
because we don't want things to get
messed up based on the name
so now we're going to be able to do some
pretty cool things this is
stuff we could kind of already do we
were using this dynamic cast or plat
from last episode to check if it was a
weapon
basically
uh
and let's see where we'll be able to use
that for the all over the place we're
going to be able to use that for our
inventory in general for any new item we
make we'll be able to use that for
classes too
but for example okay so
there's there's the base item delegate
and then we got a whole equipment setup
and maybe we'll end up moving this
equipment to a different file but i
don't think so i think it's fine here
but basically
this is the one
you want to use in your runtime code
right you want to make items
so we need to straighten that out
and we also so basically
we kind of want to say for this weapon
and armor
we don't want people to be able to
actually instantiate these
but they're going to be able to there's
no there's no good way around that
really but really what we want people to
do
is to call this
just item
delegate or rather uh item
let me get this straight out here
just item
and so item full plate mail and then in
the constructor put this new armor you
know kind of like we did with the the
warrior here
and what that's going to do is it's
going to fill out
uh this here
and this slot
as well whatever we've constructed with
so it's going to be pretty nice for
runtime it's going to change a lot of
this code so it's going to change this
equip code a little bit
uh we're going to rechange this whole
quip method to to swap with some sort of
inventory and it'll make a lot more
sense because uh inventory is going to
be
an open-ended thing like you're going to
have the player's main inventory right
or you know maybe your main stash as the
player of the game something you always
have access to you're also going to be
opening chests and loot boxes or
whatever it may be or other backpacks or
looting mobs those are essentially going
to be little inventory caches as well
and you should be able to pull from them
and either equip stuff or put it into
your inventory so we're going to build
those sort of systems and we're going to
make sure that they don't allow duping
and all kinds of stuff like that that's
that's going to be the important thing
so a little bit of boilerplate for that
but we're going to walk through it all
so
let's keep going
so this equip function is not really
going to work anymore because
from item to item delegate so what we
actually need to equip is the full plate
mail data
let's see if it likes that uh
but let's see type item delegate is
incompatible with type equipment
delegate so we need to cast this to
something else
and we can do it like this
we can say whenever you try to equip
just dynamic castle this data
to an equipment delegate and if this
fails it's going to be null if it
doesn't fail it's going to cast to the
type it is we might actually want to do
this beforehand this might be kind of
janky if we go to our equip code
we'll see that it does takes this
equipment delegate and sees checks of
its armor checks if it's a weapon and
puts it in the right slot but what we
probably want to do here is go if
uh not thing
return or return faults i guess fail
because we're equipping a bull here
because uh we want to see if they're
trying to pass null you know this
pointer could be no we want to check so
if it's null we just want to return
and not do any sort of quipping so
that's that's pretty important
but we'll keep working on this equip
function it's it's definitely going to
change quite a bit as we go we're
probably going to change some other
stuff too but i'm trying to isolate this
episode to strictly the items why don't
i have item open twice here that's kind
of weird
okay
all right so let's uh keep sorting out
this main code here
and uh
see what we can do let's go let's change
this leather helm to an item and just do
the same thing here
let's fix this
equip well let's go ahead and go
dynamic cast skew equipment delegate
start
and then letter
dot
the date the date and weather help so
that's what we're actually equipping
and let's see how that goes
uh long sword is going to be the same
thing
just an item
and we're going to make sure it sets the
data by doing this sort of thing and uh
we'll just copy this actually it's going
to be a little faster let's fill this in
the long sword there we go
copy and paste to save time
wherever you can and here's where we
start going through our class and test
the level up and uh let's check the
equipped armor check the quick weapon
apply buff you know that all that stuff
is there so let's just go ahead and run
this and see if it actually runs
and it looks like it does let's just
check that everything's correct so let's
go through this bit slowly let's start
at the top here we've got some equip
successes that's good
and uh let's go to the well so it shows
the warrior at level one right there
he's got his armor his shiny plate has
long sword and all stats no buffs no
abilities uh goes to level two
and you see he's uh seems to have
leveled up correctly he's got a buff's
got some power attacks all that good
stuff so
seems to be working pretty good
but uh
yeah i guess i guess we kind of knocked
out a main thing there it's just a
little it's just a little wonky how you
do this equip
so maybe we want to straighten this out
a little further
and we can do that
there's a there's a couple big things i
want to do that we haven't really got to
yet uh one of the big things is
we need to sort out a way where they
can't instantiate this weapon and armor
on their own
and that's a little bit tricky
but i think the easiest way to do it
here and i'm just going to test this and
see if it works if you know a super good
way
you're
you're welcome to leave a comment or
just change the code over on github but
if we just go
private on all these constructors
it makes a lot of things suddenly
illegal no one can mess with it but if
we do this if we go
somewhere in this class we go
friend class
item
that means the item is now allowed to
instantiate weapons and i'm not sure if
this is going to mess up our dynamic
casting or not we're just going to have
to kind of find out and we can do the
same thing with armor you just take this
private
oh move this armor down private all the
constructors and then somewhere in here
go friend class
item which means basically
this is now allowed to instantiate items
which is going to do
right here with this constructor
basically
maybe
oh wait actually it's not
so we need some sort of front end that
does it basically that would kind of
make more sense i think
but this has got some underlines
function definition for item not found
okay so it doesn't it's saying it
doesn't know what item is well it is
probably because
well i guess we can move this up
underneath the item delegate
specifically
because everything below it
it figures out later it's just the way
headers are they
literally only know about things above
them in headers so
something to think about keep in mind
sometimes so that's why i was
underlining that because we're saying
friend class item but there's nowhere
above in this header where it knows
where that what that is yet
that's all it is so
sometimes that causes some very
confusing errors
and it's kind of one of the
disadvantages of typing a lot of this
code that's actually going to build into
your main like that all right but let's
go ahead and try to run this and just
see what happens likely we're going to
get an error let's see yep
okay can on access private member that's
what we're getting
so there we go now we could have
some sort of item creator front end and
that's probably going to be the best way
to do it we'll just have like a
item creation manager basically in that
item creation manager
it's going to be the thing that has
permission to all these constructors
so that that is probably what we're
going to do in order to prevent a lot of
strange shenanigans that people could
try with these if we just leave
everything public
so yeah let's go ahead and do that let's
make
that item creation manager so we're
going to go new item
just do it on h file for now item
or what do we call this we'll call this
like uh
you know there's a million different
names this could be like our item
factory or item factory manager item
creator
yeah we'll just call it item item
manager
this is essentially going to be like our
extension type class so let's go back
into our items here
and we will say
you know we'll just make basically all
of these private
all of them have friend
class
item
and it's going to be the same for the
weapons
item manager
basically anything that's not those pure
virtual ones are not the delegates don't
matter so much because no one can
instantiate those anyway
but these this armor and weapons
we want to be a little more specific and
of course we're going to have to include
item manager here
all right so we take this item manager
and this class is going to be a little
bit interesting we don't want people to
instantiate item manager it's just going
to be like a set functionality for the
world builder basically so that they can
build a world as needed
with it so it's going to be a class
it's going to be a pure static class
and
we're just going to make all these
these functions public
the static keyword is optional actually
we don't necessarily need it but let's
go and go ahead and include it.h
and now
in our main we want to make sure
okay this is fine
this is where we want to make our item
creation functions so let's just make a
void our static void
create
armor
and basically we just need all the stuff
that an armor constructor would need so
let's go into our item here
go down to armor wherever it is
here it is and let's just grab all the
stuff
that it needs right here name
core stats slot
and let's put that right here
and actually i guess we need to return
an actual white
and this is we kind of do need to decide
if we want this item to be a pointer or
not
but we need to think about a little bit
of memory management if we're doing that
but some interesting things are going to
happen like if this copies it's going to
call the constructor if it calls the
constructor again it's going to make
another unique id
we don't necessarily want that to happen
so it's probably best we return a
pointer
to item since we don't want
the actual data copying we just want to
may and basically it's going to be
better to manage pointers in this case
because of those unique ids
but potions and stuff it might be a
little different because we're not going
to need to manage them so we won't need
to think about that these are the things
you need to think about in order to make
sure that you don't get
strange duping issues basically is you
know yet literally it can't be duped
right if uh there's only one of them in
your memory
and there's only one pointer allowed
that's a unique pointer so this is
actually a great candidate for unique
pointers and we'll probably refactor
that later but it's important to
understand raw pointers
that way you can understand when to use
unique pointers because they're going to
save a lot of the code like
we're going to be writing kind of a lot
of code to basically make these unique
pointers
and hopefully that'll
make more sense later for when to
actually use the unique pointer it just
basically removes a lot of the code that
you need to write when you're managing
raw pointers but should not shy away
from learning how to manage all pointers
though of course all right so
item what do we do here we just uh let's
just make a new item pointer
uh we'll just call it temp item and it's
going to equal
a new armor in this case
and let's just pass on all this stuff uh
actually that doesn't work we need to
do it as a constructor like so
uh
well this is going to look a little a
little weird
there new item new armor
and it's just yeah we kind of have a
double pointer thing going on because
you know item if we go look at our item
it's uh it's just a class
but it's data member is the thing that
is also a pointer
so
uh this being public is dangerous that's
gonna allow people to change it and
reset it and stuff uh it might even be
better
to just uh put it into private
and let people access it via getter
functions that way they can't decide to
change this that's that's going to
potentially cause a lot of the bugs that
we've discussed
so we probably want like a yet something
about the data
that would that would make a lot more
sense like get name get whatever uh
we'll do that here in a sec for now
we're just going to leave it all private
yeah right there's fine make sure the
data manager is the only thing touching
it
that way
basically the end user is restricted to
this function
and they literally can't mess anything
up if we've carefully designed how they
can use it
from a front end so this is somewhat
like our interface classic as you'd call
it there might be a lot of different
games for it but
all right so that can we make that new
item
should be fine and then we just return
that point
yeah all right
so what happens here let's think about
this real quick all right we are
returning temp item but what is template
temp item is a pointer
to this data that we created that's all
it is
so what that means is uh this data is
now hidden away
somewhere in memory and the only way we
have access to it is through this
pointer we returned this pointer is
probably returned as a copy pointer and
this old one is probably
going to be destructed so this pointer
here is going to be gone we're going to
return a new fresh one to the end user
so the end user will have
access to that which can point to the
data
or point to the item but since
everything in here is private they won't
be able to do anything except access the
public stuff and the public stuff now
let's at least make something to start
so that they're not completely lost i
guess
we could just give them some some const
access to it so we could go
const
item
delegate
get
data
this will just
return
the pointer now this is going to return
a const pointer which means they're not
going to be allowed to modify anything
in data so it's relatively safe
however a clever c plus programmer could
use const cast
on this
and uh cast the const away it'd still
change it anyway
but uh don't use const cast that's
that's the solution to that if you're
having to use const cast you've got some
design problems
um
yeah i don't know why they put kant's
cast in the c plus plus standard
honestly it's it's kind of just a thing
that's like why use const anyway if you
could just cast it away it really makes
no sense it's kind of it's kind of weird
but
this at least gives them a public way to
get to the data and then they can access
any public members here they could
access name for example
and if this data if it ends up being
some other kind of item like if it ends
up being
uh some other kind of equip if it ends
up being equipment they could access the
unique id they could access the stats if
it ends up being armor they could access
the slot and they could call this git
type
and actually item
yeah they could call
we i don't know we'll see we'll see what
they could call it's going to be
interesting because
you can't instantiate an item delegate
so whoever is creating this item it's
definitely not
just an item delegate it's got to be
it's got to be something else it's got
to be armor or weapon at this point
really there's no other options but
we'll make some other options we'll make
potions and stuff
all right so there we go we got create
armor let's go ahead and make another
function here just call this one create
weapon
and let's go to items look at our weapon
okay and
let's just grab all this stuff and put
it in our item manager
there we go and it'll do essentially the
same thing we just need to
now call this weapon and forward all
this stuff name stats slot uh we need a
min
max
whether it's two-handed or not there we
go so it's essentially gonna do the same
thing
and we've got this we'll make more as
needed
here but we're not completely done yet
there's a few things we have to think
about still mainly with this item so we
have
we have data and it's a pointer to data
but what happens when this class
destructs we need to make sure we
actually
delete the data basically so we'll just
make a destructor here and call delete
underscore data and we'll set up the
middle pointer
so yeah that'll prevent memory leaks
right there because if someone destroys
an item we want to make sure
it deletes whatever's in here because
otherwise we're starting to get the hint
about how pointers work
uh they don't manage the underlying
thing that was created that is pointing
to they just give you access to it so
it's still up to you to manage that data
that's that's really the big thing
that's that's the crux of the whole
thing
so let's go ahead and build this resolve
any errors
looks like it's complaining about
missing something
and assumed oh it doesn't it's it's
saying it doesn't know what an item is
basically
we might have a circular dependency
somewhere let me just dig in here
doesn't know what string is
okay well let's let's analyze something
this is the thing with header stuff like
this if we go to item here
notice it includes core stats then item
manager just the fact that it includes
item manager
it's going to cause issues because we
include item manager or we include item
right it's going to include core stats
and it's going to include item manager
which is going to go back here and
include item and it's going to do the
circular thing that's causing bugs let's
see if just removing that resolves it uh
not quite okay actually we're close we
just have some issues in maine now
so yeah where we can no longer do this
sort of thing we now have to say item
pointer
full plate
equals create
arm
and then we need to pass it all the
constructor stuff like so uh but this is
scoped specifically to that item manager
class so we gotta we gotta do that it
doesn't know what i'd manager is
actually of course it doesn't but we
haven't included it let's include it
very good now we're looking pretty good
here so now the equip uh we got a lot of
work to do on this equip uh what we got
wrong here oh we got one too many
parentheses there all right we don't
want to do equip like this that's a bit
dangerous we just want to do like a quip
item
so let's just get rid of all that and
just pass in the full plate mail
it's going to be up to this equip
function to understand what that is
because in theory you know you want to
be able to just like drag
your new item that you want to equip
onto your character you don't
necessarily you know just if you
generically say equip this it shouldn't
handle it correctly
so that's that's the big thing here so
this no longer should be equipped
delegate it should be
just an item pointer
and it's gonna be a little bit weird
here
uh
i want to rename this real quick thing
item to
whip that way it's kind of clear
get data
so
pointer
so it's gonna grab the data and if
there's no data there
it's just gonna return so that's going
to handle
the base case of whatever it is being
null uh i guess you know maybe we should
do another check of
making sure this to begin with is null
return
volts
there we go just handle a couple base
cases there but now these casts are
going to be a little bit different
uh
this is going to be
get
data
and it's not going to like this
so we can kind of hover over and get a
hint here
and says dynamic casts cannot cast away
const or other type qualifiers
so this being const is a problem for
this whole
this whole setup
so probably what we want to do here in
this player character is uh
uh basically well go to items here and
just allow
the player character access to this data
by just making it a print that'll
that'll be a quick fix
this is
maybe not a good long-term fix though
because
it could cause some dangers but for now
we at least won't have to use the const
function version let's see where it was
it's a search armor here
or quip
there it is
okay because now we could just go
underscore data we're allowed to access
it so now we can actually check if it's
armor or not
oh we've already checked a few base
cases made sure you're not passing in a
null item
make sure it's actually got data and
then we can go hey cast this data to
armor that succeeds
equip it to the right slot
and return true which will stop the
function if uh
if it's not armor so if this doesn't
work then
try to see if it's a weapon
so this quip function
i've said this a lot i know it's it's
going to change a lot we're going to
keep working with it until it's just
right so check if it's a weapon
check what slot it is clip to that slot
and uh notice we're doing some dangerous
things here that's kind of intended uh
see we got it to do move to inventory
instead delete so eventually what we're
going to be doing in this put function
is we're also going to be passing it a
reference to an inventory because in
theory you can't be equipping something
out of nowhere you got to be pulling it
from some inventory so we're just going
to rather than
deleting the old slot we will be moving
it out of an inventory
or
swapping the whatever you're putting in
its place into your inventory so we'll
be doing some of that kind of stuff
but for now like we said in last episode
we're just deleting the old item that
was in that place which might do some
weird stuff all right so let's see if
this builds we got a few errors
a few things just complaining about
static ignored uh i don't think you
actually need static here let's try that
uh it says we got some syntax errors
okay i guess it's probably accurate oh
yeah this equip
quick full plate mail uh what's wrong
with
that see here
okay we're just missing a parenthesis
and we've also got a few other functions
here that we need to straighten out a
little bit so we've got the full plate
mail there now we've got some leather
armor
and leather armor we can say item
we need this to be a pointer and we need
to use our create function
equals
item manager create armor once again
pass it all its stuff there
and
that
and then on the equip we can just say
equip leather helm which is so much more
clean than the other way just say equip
the leather helmet
and there we go and same with the sword
except
pointer
equals create
item monitor item manager
create weapon pass it all the descriptor
stuff
make the parentheses correct and we'll
put longsword in here
quick long sort
okay and if that is all happy we should
get successful compile which we do so
let's go ahead and hit play
and just check that that all works now
it's success
warrior's got his stuff seems to level
up okay
all right and very good we've now got
an item creation system worked out that
is a little a little better on the
memory handling and uh
should be pretty close to undoable so
stay tuned for next episode that's gonna
do it for this one thanks for
watching appreciate you guys and
appreciate the support i'll see you next
time from that out
[Music]
you